23h59
on n'a pas encore atteint et de
décrypter
notre recherche monza malades et déjà
être trop tard
le revers intel écosociologue
[Musique]
on a encore une petite fenêtre pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour éviter le fameux 2 degrés
d'augmentation des températures globales
mais sur d'autres indicateurs en termes
de perte de biodiversité en termes de
contamination chimique
il y a beaucoup d'effets qui se font
déjà sentir très gravement peu auquel on
accorde relativement qu'une importante
il faut pas investir dans des parcs line
faut pas investir dans l'extraction même
pendant l'exploration on a vu les
millions que nos gouvernements mais
c'est honteux c'est scandaleux ces
millions doivent être mis en énergies
renouvelables avant l'énergie
renouvelable même en réduction parce que
si on ne gaspille des quantités
d'énergie absolument extraordinaire une
voiture est stationnée 95% du temps est
ce que c'est une bonne utilisation des
ressources plan calcul même pas les
émissions quand elle roule je sens un
compte de ce qui est nécessaire pour la
produire
quelles sont la majorité du temps non
utilisés
ça implique des changements de
comportement est naturellement une
résistance parce qu'on est pris dans nos
habitudes
donc ça implique de repenser nos villes
aussi de repenser nos quartiers l'idéal
en fait de pouvoir être dans un endroit
où on peut faire à pied nos cours sont
pas là la garderie à l'école à pied ou
en transports en commun
on parle pas assez les effets positifs
de la pension est là on a encore près
avec l'image de sacrifices alors que
vous regardez ce qu'on s'en va qui va
être tellement mieux
claire des sociétés plus heureuse ultime
en mangeant suite convaincu se contente
de m'adresser à vous les entreprises ont
beaucoup plus ouverts qu'elle s'était
et quelle son environnement talent et
social qu'il ya dix ans l'acceptabilité
sociale c'est devenu
incontournable on est dans une société
qui pense très à court terme
quand on se met à à détruire la base de
la vie sur terre
mais c'est la base de notre vie à nous
et on fait pas souvent loin de
l'impression que l'environnement c'est
quelque chose qui est à l'extérieur de
nous on aussi une responsabilité à
l'égard de ce qui suit le comité de la
bourse et qui porte mon nom est en train
de sélectionner le prochain bourse et
nous la prochaine boursière ça permet à
des jeunes qui sont dans une situation
qui ressemble à celle dans laquelle
j'étais au moment de la fondation
d'équiterre tradition une envie de
contribuer à des solutions qui ont envie
de faire la recherche et être dans
l'action en même temps
[Musique]
il faut aller plus loin il faut pousser
il faut oser s'apprendre l'audace
[Musique]
le l'humanité à la croisée des chemins
et qu il faut qu'on prenne des décisions
importantes
quand on regarde à certains endroits ont
pesé louis hayes et roda mais on a
encore une petite fenêtre d'opportunité
mais il faut vraiment rentrer dedans
maintenant on n'a pas le temps
d'attendre encore une saison intense
[Musique]
j'ai encore l'espoir mais il va falloir
qu'on s'y mette rapidement il le premier
élément à considérer c'est que on a tous
beaucoup plus de pouvoir on serait porté
à croire
[Musique]